well let me just ask you as an aside
about uh Sacha Nadella the CEO of
Microsoft he seems to have successfully
transformed Microsoft into into this
fresh Innovative developer friendly
company I agree what do you I mean is it
really hard to do for a very large
company
uh what what have you learned from him
why do you think he was able to do this
kind of thing
um yeah what what insights do you have
about why this one human being is able
to contribute to the pivot of a large
company into something very new
I think most
CEOs are either great leaders or great
managers
and from what I observe have observed
with Satya
he is both
super Visionary really like
gets people excited really makes long
duration and correct calls
and also he is just a super effective
Hands-On executive and I assume manager
too
and I think that's pretty rare
I mean Microsoft I'm guessing like IBM
or like a lot of companies have been at
it for a while
probably have like old school kind of
momentum
so you like inject AI into it it's very
tough or or anything even like open
source the the culture of Open Source
um like how how hard is it to walk into
a room and be like the way we've been
doing things are totally wrong like I'm
sure there's a lot of firing involved or
a little like twisting of arms or
something so do you have to rule by fear
by love like what can you say to the
leadership aspect of this
I mean he's just like done an
unbelievable job but he is amazing at
being
like
clear and firm
and getting people to want to come along
but also
like compassionate and patient
with his people too
I'm getting a lot of love not fear I'm a
big Satya fan
so am I from a distance